for viewers sensitive to issues of race
be advised that the following piece
contains gratuitous use of the n-word
and by n-word
I mean nigger there I said it for the
last 15 years a man named Clayton Bigsby
has been the leading voice of the white
supremacist movement in America though
not sold in any major bookstores his
books dump truck nigger stained I smell
nigger and nigger book have sold over
600,000 copies combined despite his
popularity very few have ever seen him
due to his reclusiveness but in an
effort to bring his message to a wider
audience he agreed to give his first
public interview ever to frontline but
getting to mr. Bigsby was an odyssey in
itself riddled with backcountry hollis
shifty go-betweens and probable danger
excuse me not sure we're in the right
place we're looking for Clayton Bigsby
look now further fella you found Clayton
Bigsby the author what you don't think I
can write them books just cuz I'm blind
don't mean them do
how could this have happened a black
white supremacist our search for us is
led us here to the Wexler home for the
blind where mr. Bigsby spent the first
19 years of his life
Bridgette Wexler is the home's
headmistress well he was the only Negro
we'd ever had around here so we figured
we'd make it easier on Clayton by just
telling him and all the other blind kids
that he was white
[Music]
you've four books now I've written six
books thank publish for what would you
say is the overall message of your books
sir my message is simple naggers Jews
homosexuals Mexicans ain't Rebs and all
kinds of different shanks stick and I
hate I guess you refer to
african-americans what exactly is your
problem how much time you got buddy well
when I start well first of all they're
lazy good-for-nothing tricksters
crack-smoking swindlers big-butt
heaven wide no breathe all the white
lands their feet up all the chicken
thanks they're the best dancers hey and
they speak did I mention that before yes
I believe you did sir matter of fact my
friend Jasper telling one of them Coons
came by his house to pick his sister up
for a date he said look here nigger that
there's my girl anyone has sex and my
sister it's gonna be me
we never left this property have you mr.
Bigsby no sir not in many years what if
I were to tell you that you are an
African American listen I'm gonna make
this clear I'm in no way shape or form
involved in any of them but nothing but
now that the old skills me I have a book
signing to go to why don't you bring
your media cameras over there if you
want to see some real truth products
prudie's half - below the trip